hi everyone I'm not allowed to be on my
Channel today I'm streaming off the
potty and trying to find myself
in the game because I'm a voice actor in
this game I don't know exactly at what
point I'm at I just know I'm a DJ at a
nightclub and he'll so let's do it
followed by very unceremoniously having
to sign it for anyone who doesn't know
this games made my night school whoo
nice good reggae hole in there could
also mean oxen-free which is fantastic
there are a local la studio and I got my
voice role in this one unusually by
actually reaching out to one of my
friends who works there and being like
can I be in the game that would be super
cool when I just started boys acting and
had done some other stuff so this one
was me fully just messaging them and
being like I loved oxen-free I loved his
stuff and I love you can I help and
that's basically how it happened
ok for those just joining us this is
like an hour into the game this is uh my
level Lola I'm playing as my lower right
now I need to play as Lola though as
well and they show up in hell and they
don't know why and they have to try to
outdrink Satan to get out of hell
apparently that's the only way you can
get out
all right friends I just wanted to jump
in off to having recorded live because I
had to edit this down a fair bit because
there actually is a pretty solid chunk
of gameplay here but I thought that just
for the purposes of the video I would
give you the context on what the quest
is cuz this was maybe like two and a bit
hours into the stream so there's a lot
leading up to this point basically you
go to outdrink Satan in hell he tells
you to even be considered to have a
drinking game with him you have to go to
these other dudes to get best seals of
approval before he will actually take
you on so this part of the quest I chose
to go to Asmodeus it was one of those
people to get the seal from him and I
knew that I was part of that quest
because I remember having to record
lines about Asmodeus but yeah the whole
thing it's a longer chunk than I
expected because I don't know I I'm
gonna try not to get too sappy on it I'm
just trying to show you guys what it is
but it's so cool to be given the
opportunity to be a character that
actually has any significance in a quest
but I actually sort of drive this maybe
half hour of the game just before we
gonna do it enormous thanks to night
school it's still crazy to me that
something that I have shaped my life
around honestly moved countries for been
playing video games since I was three
it's it's the core of my being and the
fact that I have contributed to one for
a studio I really like and a game that I
think is really cool is just it's just
really awesome so thank you night school
and yeah the rest of the quest is here
just wanted to give you guys the context
of what's happening so it makes a little
bit more sense also one more note
Asmodeus makes you drink something that
as Milo what if the two lead characters
makes you like vomit up your conscience
and the DJ won't let you dance until you
have your conscience back so there's a
little part of this quest that's also
about that - alright
enjoy thank you oh this is pretty that
looks like where I might be
am I in that Club let's go it's
definitely not loud enough if I can't
hear it from you input all right let's
go yes yes yes let's go party with hell
Ilana
someone did send me a video so I know
what I look like and I again I know that
I talk about Asmodeus he might be in
here
I mean it's gonna be me school I'm
excited I'm saying
this is club' that sounds like something
a DJ would do like kind of nervous okay
still trying to find me I don't know
where I am in here that is me that's a
big guy
the monarch moodiest let's follow it
make make friends with him not that good
you better [ __ ] speak when I come
back here alone I sweat it go okay again
pretty show that's me I mean no I don't
they don't show you what the character
looks like I kind of wish they had Vicki
is especially I would have loved to know
what I look like
that's me excuse me
can you repeat yourself please the name
is written different to what except it's
so weird it does sound more Australian
than when you show British accent it's
probably because of the reading I sound
different when I read it's so weird I'm
glad we found it this is super cool I
don't think I can dance I don't think I
have the ability to I know that I say
mold and that I definitely recorded more
than three months
shuffle on down to the suggestion box
sickbay
nice work Ilana yeah you [ __ ] tell
him I wish I could dance to support
myself failure to comply well results
when a week-long stay in the Grand Hotel
of searing intestinal pain dialogue and
I don't have any context for you have to
remember that I have no understanding
what I'm saying or what the context is
I'm just gonna I definitely recorded
more than just that but I wonder if like
maybe certain parts of it I know I said
Asmodeus a lot I told people when
Asmodeus was so the fact that I've
already found Asmodeus seems odd a
wonder if it's like a timing thing with
maybe if I went up Asmodeus would be in
a different area or something what they
just changed it it's so weird it's just
so weird
okay let's talk to hideous and then
maybe come back and and see if I say
anything else
solo sauce you recognizing yourself at
that moment when you listen back to it
it was it feel really disconnected so uh
its core caught it really disconnected
um like multiple sessions for different
games off the body I think I did too so
you forget what you've said right it's I
don't we say just go and I don't [ __ ]
remember it yeah it's super disconnected
all right where do I enter oh let's do
it
I'm talking to me I'm having a
conversation with myself in a video game
really mean to myself see what happens
so now we have to go find his conscience
is that right that's right I'm gonna go
ask myself again don't mind me checking
in idiot God you look stupid
oh dude you look I don't feel like it's
not that you know wait a second I'm
smelling something weird with you you
don't have a conscience right yeah no
dancing without all of your core native
processes he was so mean Ilana why
didn't you stand up for yourself
checking in idiot God you look stupid
very beautiful Cupid you look I'm just I
just want you to know wait a second I'm
smelling something weird with you you
don't have a conscience right yeah no
dancing without all of your cognitive
processes it's down like cheating if you
don't have moral code but you do the
nightclub I'm so chill oh I wish I had
known what he could say to me give me my
questions back I just want to dance
repeating NPC here right and I'm just
walking up to myself and calling me an
idiot it's great okay it's cool to see
this in action because like he is
obviously I'm just like a bunch of
random inconsequential voices whereas in
this I control the direction of a quest
and that feels cool doing something it's
great
oh that's me I texted myself oh it's
it's no animated I haven't that's cool I
have a text service no I didn't mean to
do that
no that was an accident go back guys
yes good just a fun ride get you nobs
out it's great all right let's do it
soft Ilana tell me what to do I'm here
to check in for the dance competition
you seem a little different not that I'm
complaining
believe me who's he up against Asmodeus
who else ready when you are kid yes
please proceed to the dance for me when
ready let's dance let's do it I found
that weed when I was recording it I
gotta say about three times
it was strange she was like why am I
saying this
[Music]
save me some chili cheese and everyone
when I say about the other one I didn't
know that was a reference to the player
when I said that find a way out okay
I obviously know thank you for the
instructions self great so weird yeah I
guess I also um moonlight as a sex
competition [ __ ] run-button that's it
hey I did good
[Music]
I just announced myself as a winner the
pressure of not wanting to disappoint
you disappoint myself if I [ __ ] this up
I can't be playing this for the first
time and not do it correctly I'm right
then it would be like double
disappointment earned it here's my
official seal of approval very weird but
very cool I like the game I feel like if
I had known the setting I would have
been like maybe like a little more hype
Arruda oh I just really serve our bodies
in that thing um but otherwise totally
fine with me
totally fine ESMA deus was lovely I had
a good time it was cool that I got to
play a role that it's like dialogue
option orientated where yeah I would
record multiple outcomes depending on
what you say which can be tough because
you have to like swap between what your
mood is in really quick succession but
it's interesting to have to do so that
was that thank you all for watching uh
this might have been one of my longest
dreams of it - I know it's yeah I will
do this for every other game I'm ever in
because it's cool getting to do it why
it was really fun so thank you guys for
joining me uh I will see you guys next
time but